all right welcome back to New rockstars
and Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania may
have a small package but as Jane Van
Dyne is to be believed it's a small
package with a big surprise in store
just like my wife said to me just
kidding um
because she says in the trailers that
there are important things that she has
yet to tell her long lost loved ones
um and I think some some
could include a secret baby
secret baby a secret baby baby
that's what I call Jessica hey super
baby
this is Rogue Theory the show where we
pitch the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles that we love my name is Mt and
growing work with me today is the
wonderful the amazing Jessica Clemons
hey happy to be here chuck oh thank you
wow short and sweet
looks like there's a collision on I-5
tonight I don't know
several people died this is dangerous to
have us all in the same room
and the um amazingly
um talented and beautiful Whitney again
oh man you guys we got Wings last week
we got Wings it was so nice way
Wild Child buff and tough yeah and we
have the buffets in the toughest round
Tommy correct what's going on look at
all this head in this Frame
[Applause]
the microphones are peaking right
[Laughter]
anyway all right this leads us to our
first topic of today I believe that
Janet Van Dyne had a baby in the quantum
realm and that baby is uh named Nadia
Van Dyke who is actually a character
from the comics who becomes the next
wasp and I think that this makes a lot
of sense considering that the word Nadia
means hope and if you think about the
fact that Jennifer died was trapped in
the quantum realm and she missed her
family it would make a lot of sense if
Janet were to find a new man I mean like
it is against the laws of marriage I am
a big proponent of marriage and staying
true to your partner but if you are in
the quantum Realm you may have the
hanky-panky with somebody else
and so I think that Janet Van Dyne
um didn't want to tell
um Hank and I took a sip at the wrong
time
oh dear
oh yeah but I really do think that Jenna
Van Dyne didn't want to tell Hank and
hope about her her relationship with
potentially
um Mr Groundhog Day himself Bill Murray
oh
what if it's always Groundhog Day in the
quantum realm so they have to [ __ ] every
single oh my God because it's just the
same day over and over again what if she
got stuck in a groundhog day time loop
with Bill Murray in the quantity no
world has enough cigarettes
I like the idea of a realm pass I think
we need that you have a round pass
you're in another world exactly
you see Jonathan majors in the quantum
realm you go crazy I see Michelle fight
for in the quantum realm I get my hands
on it
yeah they're uh it's it's scientifically
proven that people are hotter in the
quantum realm um that's just how it
works I don't know but yes everyone
deserves a Quantum realm pass uh but no
I think that this would be a really
smart way to sort of
um just set up the next generation of
Watts because like we know that um
Evangeline Lily is probably not going to
be lost forever and um I think that the
the title of wasps is going to move on
to a different person and so like we
know that uh stature is probably going
to end up taking the man to love Ant-Man
in her own way and I think that uh we're
also going to get Nadia Van Dyne the
Unstoppable wasp which is a fantastic
comic series I think you should give it
a look
um uh she is a just a super smart person
because she's the the daughter of Hank
Pym but I think it'd be really fun if
she made her the daughter of Janet Van
Dyne so that um Nadia Van Dyke her the
last name Van Dyne would make sense
um versus Pim quick question quick
interjection she's Nadia Pym in the car
in the comics but you think she's going
to be Nadia Van Dyne in the movie so
she's 90 of Van died in the comics but
she's she's technically the daughter of
Hank Pym well what if him is him is the
one [ __ ] around while his wife's wife
exactly
he's dead so that's not even like cheese
that's like you're a widow man
he was being such a little baby [ __ ]
boy about it like he was out in the
world he was a little baby baby boys can
still get dicks
like it when they see a man crying in a
bar they're like I can fix it if I see a
white man crying in a bar and I'm not
gonna fix him yeah you don't have a baby
[ __ ] boy fetish
afraid to talk to people because he's
like no matter what at the end of the
day I still got my woman I still got my
that was the person I lived for I died
for but I love Michelle Pfeiffer being
like I didn't think like that
urges hey man she's smart she's smart
you know nerds nerds be freaky I just
figured it out oh I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna over row your Rogue Theory Janet
Van Dyne was pregnant when she got
shrunk in and trapped around
raise that child
too adulthood and that child said I
don't want to escape but like that
that's how I was like I'm happier Janet
was like no we've got to figure out a
way out we've got to keep signaling the
child's like no my friends
[Music]
maybe it was Nadia Van Dyne or maybe it
was Nadia Van Dyne and Bill Murray has
just grown older in the quantum realm
and his Janet Van Dyne and Hank pins
pin's son
that man is not attractive enough to be
Michelle Pfeiffer son I am sorry oh it's
movie Magic even Bill Murray in his
youngest hottest primeest time is not
hot enough to be Michelle Pfeiffer's son
I agree but Michael Douglas is kind of a
Crypt Keeper isn't he no he's pretty
women will say Michael Douglas is hot
before going to therapy you know what
I'm saying I would rather say Michael
Douglas is attractive are girls okay
oh I've seen disclosure he's hot I mean
all right he's hot as sheesh I mean I I
can see him being a gilf I don't know I
I'm not attracted to men but I think
he's a good kill he's a great
grandfather had like a good gift
Greg Gandalf I'd like me you shall not
not just a kid though like because
obviously there's the Nadia Van Dyne
piece but like we know that Janet Van
Dyne is a scientist and like she um is
so curious about the quantum realm and
just like just advancing to um science
and all that stuff what if Jenna Van
Dyne made like a machine or something
um that she's just really ashamed of
that Kang is probably one it's the
machine from uh the the Coen Brothers
movie that's the bicycle that has the
sex toys
it's too powerful
I really appreciate that this is what
all the years I was down here this is
all I built
[Laughter]
but no I think that there's a good
chance that a Kang might want her to
might want Scott to steal a piece of
Jana Van Dyne technology because like
you know we know that like Janet and
Hank like changed the game with the pen
particles like they changed it like
everybody wants them like literally
Hank's entire life was just him trying
to hide the pin particles and like Janet
is the half of that key like he did not
do that by himself and I think that um
that is going to factor into the quantum
realm a lot because once you have like a
smart person introduced into any type of
plane in the MCU like the technology
advances like like so fast and so um I
think that she accidentally may have
made something that she shouldn't have
potentially but it could be a baby could
be a computer I don't know
yeah baby computer anyway
[Laughter]
I think I I know I normally I'm like
but what was that again
[Laughter]
but I it's all sound okay I genuinely
I'll take well the road is what do you
guys think it's definitely rogus I mean
that is a rogue rogue of a rogue it's
either a baby or a laptop like that's a
great way from a computer
tablet what are those you can either
gave birth to an iPad or to a young
child and I'm okay with either I gave
birth to a Modoc oh
yeah
I'm leaving I'm walking that would be
right now yo if I was a doctor and Modoc
came out of somebody's hoo-ha I would
slap that baby because Modoc is I would
put it back in you'd be like get back in
there he's like please I don't want to
see this anymore disgust aim I think
that situation could still be again
another sound situation of the baby
coming out of the quantum realm as Modoc
and then it's eventually gonna be Hank
Pym and Janet are gonna make aim a big
situation and modoc's gonna be like this
is my papa's company and take it over
eventually because that's what he did in
the comments
my Birthright let's wait till my papa
here's this
um putting a modak back inside a baby
Mark just try and put a can of Folgers
crystals
that's you've ever seen those tubes
those big Folgers tubes that's what
putting the Modoc back in would be well
yeah you can't put
that
too
I don't know um you guys have a bad
attitude about it right you guys have to
believe in yourself because if you just
shove it right back in I'm giving it a
lesson you can't okay
leave a baby up with baby oil and just
like okay
I want to give it a rogus and quickly
scroll up
this is why they don't invite me back to
California I'm just kidding yeah
all right so wait three Rogue is this is
that yeah
well I got my first IRL rocus I feel so
wow can't wait to get my boy
but up next Jess has a really amazing
theory that we cannot wait to hear but
first be sure to check out new
rockstarmurch.com for the perfect gifts
this holiday season and it's not just
shirts and hoodies on the site no you
can also grab enamel pins patches hats
and stickers oh my God it needs make the
perfect surprise gift since you don't
need to know the sizes you don't
surprise the new rockstars fan in your
life with some Brandon Merch this year
and support the channel check out all of
the awesome merch options available at
new rockstarsmerch.com
um and we also want to thank rocket
money for sponsoring this podcast
because did you know how much of your
subscriptions really cost most Americans
think that they spend around 80 a month
on subscriptions when the actual cost is
closer to like 200 plus dollars that's
right you could be wasting hundreds of
dollars each month on subscriptions that
you don't even know about isn't that
ridiculous should you have more money
yes you deserve more money there's an
app I love using that takes care of that
for me it's called Rocket money the app
shows you your subscriptions in one
place and then cancels for you whatever
apps that you do not want it is
literally like I don't know what type of
Technology they're using but like it has
saved me so much money rocket money can
even find subscriptions that you didn't
even know you were paying for they find
that I can't say a bad word they find it
and you may even find out that you've
been double charged for a subscription
which would be ridiculous I hope that
you're horrible
happens to anyone out here rip Mike
exactly
so to catch your subscription all you
have to do is press cancel and Rocket
money takes care of the rest so super
simple get rid of useless subscriptions
with rocket money right now go to
rocketmoney.com Rogue seriously it can
save you hundreds per year that's
rocketmoney.com Rogue cancel your
unnecessary subscriptions right now at
rocketmoney.com Rogue
and we also want to thank smile
brilliant because if you have ever
considered whitening your teeth you
might be confused by all the variations
of teeth whitening on the market
thankfully smile brilliant is here to
explain the science behind teeth
whitening to make you feel comfortable
about choosing the correct method stop
the expensive guess and test method when
it comes to teeth whitening and oil care
stop guessing many of the at-home
products on the market don't even work
as intended LED lights are a novelty
item strips neglect from the gum lines
crevices and molars often making
remaining stains be more prominent plus
strips use hydrogen peroxide which
always results in Greater tooth
sensitivity in comparison to carbamide
peroxide charcoal is abrasive and wear
down the enamel and whitening toothpaste
only works on Surface stains like
charcoal is abrasive so it works the
number one product recommended by
dentists is the custom fitted tray
historically dispensed only by dentists
at a price of 300 to 1 000 that changed
more than 10 years ago when smile
brilliant came up with the Innovative
lab direct process head over to
smilebrilliant.com and get the custom
fitted teeth whitening trays or night
guards if you grind your teeth they also
have a whole whole Suite of professional
oral care products such as an electric
toothbrush water flosser Dental
probiotics and much more and right now
they're having a holiday sale with
discounts up to 50 of the normal price
so freshen your breath and look with
Rogue 5 and save an additional five
percent off on their holiday sale that's
code Rogue five at smilebrilliance.com
Rogue five standing by you broke five
standard bye
but now this leads us to our second
topic of today which the brilliant and
beautiful Jessica Clemens will tell us
about right now go I'm not beautiful
either way that's a lie that's a lie
that's weird
beautiful ass out of here
um look at that sweet beautiful angels
get her out of here you guys you guys so
much stuff has hit today you know that
we shoot Rogue theory on Thursday or
comes out over the weekend and today is
the day that we have heard so much news
about Wonder a woman and Warner Brothers
and James Gunn and Peter saffron going
forward so Peter Safford and James Gunn
presented their plans to Warner Brothers
and uh the sequel to Black Adam Man of
Steel Wonder Woman are not on that list
according to many sources but a lot of
other sources are saying that it's just
super highly unlikely for those movies
to get a sequel seeing what they're
doing so if we say goodbye to Man of
Steel if we say goodbye to Henry Cavill
the poor man that literally left The
Witcher franchise to play Superman I'm
sorry I'm only laughing because I'm like
this if you put all his eggs in one
basket now just to have that cut from
that poor guy uh what would he be
playing so today my throgue theory is I
think Henry Cavill will be playing
Bizarro Superman oh no now hear me out
let me give you some more notes about
what happened with Warner Brothers and
James Gunn okay and we'll also probably
be talking about this on the break room
that appears today on this Thursday so
you could probably go to that for more
and more details uh additionally seeing
as this is the Zack's not writer like
Zack Snyder's characters like the ant
the Aquaman the Gal Gadot Wonder Woman
Henry Cavill Superman you what have you
uh we don't know what really lies there
with their contracts or just the
ownership so the idea could be also
riding on the fact that it's the Snyder
verse and they need to let go of that
right and I think I don't know about you
guys but it's like yeah sometimes you
gotta let stuff grow From the Ashes you
know like the Snyder verse had like took
its toll and it did all these things and
you can't really grow uh the like the
DCU now without kind of having to let
those things go so what you're saying is
that we should restructure the hierarchy
I thought we already did that I thought
that that happens
on the list
he didn't restructure this is true that
kicked off the structures
to be fair yeah what's the difference in
restructure and just getting voted
seriously like oh man like yeah like one
time I got restructured from Haagen-Dazs
for getting out too many sandwiches
that's how people kind of do with like
being fired it's like hey we're kind of
just
restructuring nature uh either way I
think this is all a little likely
because like James Gunn said in Twitter
no one knows the plans going forward but
him and Peter saffron and though Henry
Cavill did tweet after Black Adam
Premiere after the Black Adam premiered
that he was excited to play Man of Steel
again I'm not laughing at this it's just
so crazy why are you roasting every day
the first one upset about what he that
he had to leave but the fact that like I
think the actors are actually not in the
know about getting kind of put to the
sidelines because he tweeted that after
um the Black Adam Premiere and Gal Gadot
tweeted like a couple days ago that
she's excited to play Wonder Woman right
and then both those things got cut so I
think it's very likely that maybe Man of
Steel will not be Man of Steel anymore
but I think that doesn't say that we
shouldn't say yes to Henry Cavill like
he was a good actor I think he say yes
to him
I'll say Yes to the Dress I think that
this all means that none of us are
allowed to tweet I'm so glad I'm a host
at new Rockstar as soon as you tweet
that you have no idea what I have in
store this year at new Rockstar I'm so
looking forward to continuing my role at
this company like Jesus now you're not
allowed
Jinx is your man it really jinxes you
don't don't do it so with all that
knowledge behind me though all the
knowledge I said I do think think that
we should keep Henry Cavill in the DCU I
think you should stay I think he's great
if we're planning on trying to keep uh
Jason Momoa as Lobo now instead of
Aquaman try doing something like that
with Superman and I do think it's funny
but I do think James Gunn would take
that into her and be like yeah it's
making him bizarre or Superman bro I
would freaking love that because I love
Bizarro so much it's so fun and like I
think that a uh uh a Henry Cavill
bizarre Superman would he's a great
actor and I feel like bizarre was just
so unique and like he's like especially
like over the recent years when like I
think it was the Red Hood run Bizarro
and red hood where um you know we just
see a different side of Bizarro and he's
amazing this guy is he just you know
he's misunderstood he's misunderstood
he's bizarre a Superman yeah like I sort
of like you know Solomon Grundy from uh
yes the the JLA tournament series uh
specifically
um like he was just like this like
tragic villain sort of he's like I'm
dumb and big but like I just I don't
know what I'm doing
um I like that I like a good dub big
character I'm like that is like James
Gunn you know he does Groot and like he
does uh uh the shark one from uh Suicide
Squad
and so like Bizarro was just another one
of those and James Gunn would knock that
out of the park I think he could I I
again he could play probably anything
his Henry Cavill is a great actor but
easy enough to do kind of funny to do uh
kind of just like yeah let's just make
him the opposite anti's Superman also
James Gunn has been tweeting
periodically a bunch of DC cryptic
messages of like here's different
characters
and uh there is a Bizarro but it's in
the same photo as a superman but there
has been that photo of dead man that he
posted first that was like the original
and I do think he would play a really
good dead man because dead man I think
is needs good acting needs good acting
because he's he's just ah so it's like I
think Henry Cavill could do that
that was different did you all like it
remember the first one was yeah yeah
all
right
talk
you're making like noises that Quagmire
would make if he was sexually excited
uh but yeah uh I guess yeah so that's my
theory is that I think James Gunn will
get rid of a lot of the Snyder verse yes
correct but I think he will pull Henry
Cavill on when he pulls Henry Cavill
I'll have him play bizarros by Spiderman
Spiderman he would be a very bizarre
Spiderman he really was wow
Spider-Man with a CGI mustache
when he had that weird like rotating lip
line that's so great Honestly though
well first of all I want to give this
aerobics because like I love this so
much but like what do you think of the
idea of Henry Cavill potentially coming
back to play Batman oh to be Batman yeah
I think he would do a great job I think
he should have been Batman before
Superman come for me if you want I I
understand that's really crazy kind of
stupid but I do think he's such a good
actor Henry Cavill you can you're not
wasting him if you put him in a role
like that I think he would have been
such a good job he's [ __ ] huge yeah
dude and like if you if he was actually
Batman in real life like you would mess
like villains up the closest they that's
why they gave him Superman because
Superman is always jacked right that's
true but I would if they brought him
back I would I think the fans would get
mad but I would not I genuinely would
not I think it'd be so fun let him try
it okay go for it there's not many more
Batmans for a while this is true
I love Batman because there's so many
battles I don't know why I love that
every time I don't not love them I just
need a little tiny I just need to hit
the snooze button Keep It Coming treat
it like you guys there's Batman yeah we
need a break introduce some more um like
more obscure listen to me listen to me
go to camera four oh wait that's Tommy's
camera
[Laughter]
yeah I got my point across yes uh I'm
gonna God this is gonna cause so much
strain on our friendship I'm giving you
a bogus
oh my God
nothing you said was wrong I just I
think that we are in the overreactions
phase of the announcement that Wonder
Woman three has that iteration which was
the phrasing this current iteration of
Wonder Woman 3 is not going forward is
considered dead it doesn't mean there
won't be a Wonder Woman 3 presented by
James Gunn and Peter saffron and whoever
else it just means whatever idea they
had whatever whatever script was written
for that right is not what we're gonna
see I think that uh what we're gonna end
up with is these characters in a
different just just kind of rebooted
similar to Daredevil being rebooted over
at Marvel and being born born again on
Disney plus I think we're gonna see
Henry Cavill as Superman maybe it will
be called Man of Steel maybe it'll just
be called like the amazing Superman or
the whatever the uh I just I just feel
like right now rightfully so we're all
in a state of like what is happening
because this is a big thing can I can I
say one thing no yes you may say do you
remember when we did the break room and
it was about
um like a 14 page Rolling Stone about
what Zack Snyder did and one of those
things was Warner Brothers not being
able to work with Gal Gadot and all the
original Justice League characters
because the new the new Warner Bros
being like we can't because Zack Snyder
hired these people and Zack Snyder has
some kind of form with these people like
some kind of contract and the thing is
they're afraid to I think genuinely
they're afraid to touch them because
once they do that Snyder and the Snyder
Furs can do whatever they kind of want
they can start being like all right
those aren't characters we gotta get it
we gotta we gotta get our legal team on
that yeah
I've never heard of that before of like
a director having autonomy over that I
read that I wrote this episode and I
genuinely was like this is insane I
always make the whole Tim Burton has
custody of Johnny Depp thing make a lot
of questions
[Laughter]
please go to sleep you've been up four
days give me another Mega pint
s
all right I give you a bogus I love it I
give you a bogus but I wrap it in all
the love uh in my heart I'm not taking
it I'm giving you a rogus but only if
you let me keep the CGI mustache on him
yes
dead man with a mustache mustache that's
so funny uh yes okay thank you Jess this
was an amazing thank you Jessica this is
my second live of the break room on the
set it's been fun second second bogus uh
Zach gave me the first one well Zach and
I are uh very alike we plan this
together we're cut from the same
beautiful cloth we also want to thank
Miracle brands for sponsoring this
podcast because you know that your
temperature at night can have one of the
greatest impacts on your sleep are you
sleeping well well if you wake up too
hot or too cold I highly recommend you
check out Miracle Brands bed sheets yeah
inspired by silver infused Fabrics made
by at this NASA they sent people to the
Moon
maybe uh Miracle brand makes temperature
regulating bedding
Maybe
they send people to the food I don't
know if that's true but I mean I believe
there's silver inside Tommy's also
against medicine
I don't
Miracle brand makes temperature
regulating bedding so that you can sleep
at the perfect temperature all night
these sheets are infused with natural
silver that prevents 99.9 of bacterial
growth leaving them to stay cleaner and
fresh three times longer than other
sheets your other sheets are disgusting
clean sheets means less bacteria to clog
your pores and fewer breakouts and other
skin problems Miracle sheets are
luxuriously comfortable you feel the
luxury on your skin your pores smile
without the high price tag or other
luxury Brands so go to try miracle.com
Rogue to try it today or even better yet
because it's the holiday season gift it
to someone that you love you love people
right you want them to feel good and
sleep well well buy them this freaking
blank it save over 40 and be sure to use
our promo code Rogue at checkout to save
even more and get my goodness three free
towels you will never be wet again
[Laughter]
anyway um
[Applause]
and Miracle is so confident in their
product it's backed with a 30 day money
back guarantee so if you aren't 100
satisfied you will get a full refund
refund so upgrade your sleep with
Miracle Brands so go to try america.com
Rogue and use the code Rogue to claim
your free three-piece towel set so you
can be dry and save over 40 off again
that's trimirical.com
Rogue to treat yourself a friend or
loved one this holiday season thank you
to miraclebrand for sponsoring this
episode but now it is time for our bro
question
you guys ready let's go
now that the current plans for Wonder
Woman 3 have been taken off the DCU
slate how would you like to see Wonder
Woman return in a film from Warner
Brothers Oh Tommy already said his in a
Scooby-Doo movie
[Music]
say goodbye to a friend of ours
Wonder Woman
that was the current Place we've been
taking off the DCU slate how would you
like to see Wonder Woman return in a
film from Warner Brothers
uh could you put her in Oppenheimer
Grasso a wrestle of Ruth a wrestle a
roof I would love to see a live-action
Scooby-Doo Crossover with like a
legitimate like job not in my YouTube
oh that's right he's like well it
doesn't matter it just says I was just I
was just joking I want to see Wonder
Woman played by Beyonce oh do you yes
I'll say it right here and I've said it
before you go to camera four
oh Beyonce can't act oh my God all right
I'm gonna say something kind of
controversial
camera four oh
whatever four either can Gal Gadot oh
okay you know what do you mean I'm here
what's this cheese
I know she's a fine actress yeah Beyonce
played a great foxy whatever her name
was listen I watched obsessed you ever
watch obsessed between Beyonce
yes you're gonna say Beyonce did the
best job listen she just has that like
that white lady took her child and she
she went off on her okay so I say
Beyonce Beyonce can act real family
for the last 10 years
Jacks every time she's court-sighted I
love my husband I can't come back I'm
never coming back after that one listen
to that lemonade song it looks pretty
good well anyways my watch just worn
them in a loud environment my ears might
be
well for my pitch I would like us to
remember for once you sexist pigs okay
because there's also a Warner sister dot
oh oh okay so I want to see dot play
Wonder Woman oh I think that the one her
sister needs to be like hey [ __ ] you
Warner Brothers right it's all about
lady time
I want someone to deliver a Wonder Woman
costume to the the Warner Brothers water
tower four dots four dots specifically
just like a little cute one just like a
little yes like she needs I I would love
to see that I want the Animaniacs to
have their own movie honestly honestly
I'm like it's about time
the reboot was really good did you watch
the Animaniacs no it's actually very
very
really quick
Reika
Reiki massages oh my God
Reiki massages get this outro and then
let's get out of this episode but I'm
gonna give Whitney the Rogue questions
[Applause]
but that is it for this episode of Rogue
Theory thanks to our guests Justin
Clemens Whitney van leningham and Tommy
Beck told support our Channel by
checking out all of our awesome merch
over at New rockstarsmerch.com and uh
you can follow me at masterton if you
want to see me tweet some weird [ __ ] but
more importantly you could just
um just say hi to us on Twitter and just
be nice to us and um so subscribe to our
channel here on YouTube because um it's
the best way to keep up with our content
we love you guys so much thank you for
spending time with us and we'll see you
guys later goodbye
[Music]
Tommy they're done
[Music]
thank you